hi and welcome to Sarah's music we're
back in bond at the annual Beethoven
fest and today we have an unusual
combination of artists for you a famous
piano duo a rock guitarist a drummer and
seven break dancers and how that's all
going to work we'll find out the break
dancers who are also known as be boys
arrived from Paris and immediately
filled the beethoven holla with their
energy katia and marielle avec invited
them to take part and David Sharman
star-crossed lovers a modern day romeo
and juliet the dancers told me that
dancing in front of a mainly classical
music audience is a very special event
for them here we are again ketchum
Arielle welcome back to thursday's you
we're here in bond today and it's a very
unusual combination we have a to
classical classically trained pianist we
have a rock guitar we have a drummer and
we have break dancers how did this
project come about levy chairman
invented this cool Iran Denise of homeo
and Juliet for especially for llaman oku
to choreography with his seven dancer
breakdance so Marielle how would you
describe this music because it's how
it's hard to put in an inner genre but
we don't have to put it in a jean now we
don't have to decide what I love about
you you girls you're always pushing
these barrier it's a new music and just
you know using electronic and you know
having Giants and the piano and it it
has a lot of character and he goes
extremely well with the ballet because
you can I mean especially when you you
hear the music with the dancer then it
becomes clear that the story that you
know what he's saying with the music but
it's a totally different different thing
I mean to module three for you both I
mean to work with dancers one thing but
they break dancers how did they react to
the music they heard an amazing I had to
see there's been only pleasure to work
with them
the beautiful spirit and the very hard
worker it's a lot of classical done yes
it is not from them but they have to do
padded with dental more denser Juliet
she's contact free dancer she's not
break dancer but of course I have to
carry her and in break dance that does
not exist they never carry a woman so
that was very new for them and also for
them to remember this kind of music we
could then he ties a story and you know
it will it was hard so I'm really
looking forward to the performance thank
you so much and its really very powerful
music really electrifying and and you
you are a great Montague and Capulet
family
[Music]
you
[Music]
don't think
[Music]
naveed welcome to bond thank you it
looks terribly complicated not only the
composer but you control all these
sounds with your feet with your hands
with your guitars and you keep an eye
out on what's going on almost a dancer
here sometimes but yeah tell me how did
this come about I mean Romeo and Juliet
it's it's a fantastic story to put to
music a lot of people down it before you
how did it come about the idea of the
ballot was quite challenging and as you
said Romeo and Juliet I try not to think
too much of other people doing it you
know you shouldn't think about that when
you start writing you know the sisters
very well you know there's their
strength you know who does walk very
well and you've divided the stage a
little bit you have the Montagues in the
captain yes so with the Capulets on this
side and the end the Montague on the
other side and yeah writing for KTM I'll
is amazing because I I've been recording
them for a long time so working in the
studio and I of course master watch lot
of shows and they're so different in so
complimentary that's how are they
different uh well mari el is really good
on the rhythm and the lows and the crazy
strong bases and the catcher is a
melodic and brilliant and fast and so
what you wrote yeah i wrote for them in
his thinking of that
[Music]
[Music]
you
yeah man what I love about doing my
program is is discovering these new art
forms and today I'm discovering rape
dancing one of the best things you said
to me today was that you discovered this
sort of classical music through doing
this project yes yes yes with the
lebesgue sister and the first time I saw
them me was a I was touring with the
Madonna and their friends so we were
playing performing in Rome and they were
in rooms we came to play for you yeah
yeahs invited us to their house and we
went there and I saw them playing phase
two like face to face like this and I
was amazed I was up what a what is this
in a I felt like I felt like I had to
dance so I just danced and they were
they saw me dancing so did they kept
playing and the other dancers came and
they dance to and then we talked we
became you know not friends but uh we
talked a lot and then they came they
came up with this idea and they said
young man we need you to dance with
their to dance with us with them on this
show and I said let me Cora grab
something with some very good dancers so
how do you go about teaching these guys
who are maybe not used to doing set
choreography the dancers I'm working
with I know them very good and after
I've chosen them because of their moves
that I like so I know exactly who has
some special moves so I know exactly how
to put their own moves and use them on
the music because and me I do think that
break dancing has the perfect moves for
classical classical music this is not
the sort of music they would listen to
at home on their headphones no not at
all Greg dancing is something I know
it's raw it's very like it's comes from
anger it's it's the foundation because
because of the gangs before you know but
now I mean we can use it like the way we
want it can be very slow some some
breakdancers are doing some very hard
moves in slow motion you know so we can
use it a
in the speed we want on the music woman
we can do break dance on any music it's
there is no limit is it difficult for
them to learn because they're so used to
improvising is it to learn this
choreography well for some of them it
was the first time they went on stage
doing a show Wow and to me it was really
it was real because i wanted i wanted
them to keep this breakdance attitude
you know I didn't want to them to be
like you know dancers on stage to me no
I wanted them to be themselves as a
b-boy as a breakdancer you discover
classical music to the Vexin I've now
discovered breakdown sync you go
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is this business that's all from Sarah's
music for today
[Applause]
on one hand back here here here yeah a
horn challenge is usually when you have
to play but because you were such
amazing dancers I just want to see what
you would do with this I'm gonna just
just just move just wanna see how you
move
but don't drop it you promise
[Music]
Oh